welcome to the science Asylum I am Nick
lucid BPM minor was wondering why can we
see through glass but not through a wall
can you please explain it
yes BPM yes I can from a purely
mechanical standpoint it's actually more
surprising that more things aren't
transparent
I mean atoms are mostly empty space this
is a pretty typical visual of an atom
but sizes have been exaggerated so you
can see everything it actually looks
more like this so it seems weird that
photons of light can't just pass right
through why isn't everything transparent
electrons are greedy little quantum
physics review time here are some things
you should know about electrons and
atoms one electrons do not have size
their point particles no size two they
can only occupy certain energy levels
those levels are different for different
types of atoms and also depend on how
the atoms are bonded three since energy
is definite position is not until
something tries to find out where it is
it's in a superposition of all the
places there like that jerk on the
subway that manages to take up three
seats if electrons are simultaneously
everywhere then the photon is gonna hit
one no matter what and electrons are
greedy
so it'll absorb the photon no matter
what wait I thought you said they can
only be at certain energy levels so
doesn't that mean that can only absorb
certain types of light it depends on
what you mean by absorb you might have
seen other YouTube videos explaining
glass this way it is true that electrons
can only jump up energy levels when you
give them just the right type of light
but let me make something very clear
jumping up energy levels is not the only
way electrons can absorb light if it
were there would be no such thing as
reflection or refraction which is
ridiculous
clone get in the particle machine you
become a photon seriously that's always
so uncomfortable yes awkward Emma's
already there takes super energetic
clone with you who I have a lot of
energy and I'm gonna make a super great
awesome photon alright accident
electrons may be greedy but they're also
very picky about how they absorb the
light take this electron for example hi
crazy when just the right guy
I mean photon comes along she gets
excited
like SuperDuper lot oh I like you too
and she jumps to a higher energy level
if she's an electron and a gas molecule
she'll calm down by releasing a new
photon however if she's in a typical
liquid or solid molecule then the other
molecules are too close and she's far
more likely to calm down by giving up
that energy to move the other molecules
that increases the thermal energy
instead of releasing a photon when the
wrong guy I mean photon comes along it
tries to get her excited but fails
miserably hey baby get out of here the
photon was still absorbed by the
electron but then immediately rejected
he just doesn't do it for the reason
things like reflection and refraction
happen is because in real life there
isn't just one photon in one electron
there's a ton of each there are so many
photons hitting so many electrons that
photons are just going everywhere inside
the glass those photons interfere and
cancel each other in most places where
they don't cancel you get the light we
actually see travelling in a new
direction determined by how the atoms
are organized but why is glass
see-through and a wall isn't alright
that's what this video is about isn't it
do you remember what we said earlier
about electrons they can only occupy
certain energy levels those levels are
different for different types of atoms
and also depend on how the atoms are
bonded that part about bonding is
especially important when atoms bond to
each other to form solids the energy
levels move closer together to form
bands this leaves large energy gaps
between them the gap between bands in
glass is about 9 electron volts
which is too big for visible light to
excite electrons the photon has to have
an energy of at least 9 electron volts
which means it's wavelength must be at
most
138 nanometers that's ultraviolet light
if visible light can't excite electrons
then it won't get absorbed as thermal
energy it still gets absorbed just as
the vibration and the electrons instead
and since the electrons always reject
those photons they make it out the other
side transparency so what's the worst
glass thing you've ever broken be
transparent about it in the comments and
until next time remember it's okay to be
a little crazy